thank you for coming
to hear about monads so
my name is karen meyer and i work for
edge case
and i love stories so um i read stories
i read stories to my kids stories teach
us
stories entertain us in fact stories
i heard in the news the other day can
even help us with problem solving
a problem solving is actually increased
when you present the problem
in the context of a story rather than
just thinking about the problem
itself so with this is my background
this is not just going to be a talk
about monads this is going to be a story
about monads
and our story begins with alice
alice is a computer developer she's been
developing software for quite a number
of years
and she's been happy living in the lands
of objects
she loves objects she makes objects she
modifies objects
she takes these objects and puts them
together to make
large things and small things and in
fact
she's so comfortable with objects that
when she looks at the world around her
she just can't think of another way that
you could model it
other than using objects and she was
pretty happy
until one day she met closure
and closure rocked her world it got her
out of this object-oriented box
and she saw this new wonderful vista of
functional programming
and she fell in love she started reading
books about closure
she started reading blog posts about
closure
she started following people on twitter
that talked about closure
and one day when she was reading a blog
post
about closure of course she came across
a very strange word
monad
she let it go this time
she was interested about closure and she
wasn't going to worry about this so she
went on her merry way
reading more blog posts and again
monad it just kept cropping up
over and over again she'd read some more
and again monad
and again monad what the heck is this
momad so she figured she could do
what only about every one of us would do
is
she decided that she was going to take
on her lunch break
and um actually grab a coffee
and read through wikipedia and some blog
posts on monads
and figure out what this stuff was so
she did that she went to the coffee shop
she sat down devoted a whole hour
read wikipedia read the blog post at the
end of the lunch
she had no idea still
what monads were so she decided i'm not
giving up
you know it cannot get to me this easily
i just need to devote more time
instead of lunch i'm going to devote a
whole evening
and she set herself up for success by
making sure
she had a nice plate of cheese oh
goodness
solution okay we'll see if we'll work
she's a nice place of cheese and some
crackers and some wine
and it was a cold night so she had to
make sure that there's a nice fire in
the fireplace
and she sat in her comfy chair next to
her favorite
books so she's ready she's going to
devote a whole evening to monads
she's got her books she's got her cheese
she's got her fire
and she's got one other important thing
and this is
phillip wadler's papers she's going to
look at
two of them which is one is
comprehending monads
and the other is moon adds for
functional programming
and so she sits down and she's sitting
by the fire and she's eating her cheese
and crackers
and um the first thing that she notices
that not only is his papers brilliant on
monads
but they're also in poetry there's
poetry in them
so the first line in monads for
functional programming it begins with
shall i be pure or impure i mean this is
poetry
and not only is a poetry it explains
beautifully the two communities in
functional programming
there is the pure functional programming
side and then there's
impure functional programming side on
the pure side of course
you have all the benefits of equational
reasoning
which allow us to have lazy evaluation
but then again on the impure side
you get very practical things that are
very handy such as state
air handling and input output and
basically side effects
and pure languages of course are haskell
and
impure ones are our favorite closure and
scheme
so madler goes on to
give us another piece of poetry
is there a way to combine the
indulgences of impurity and the
blessings
of purity so
in other words is there a way that we
could have our cake
and eat it too so enter
ingenio moji i hope i pronounced that
right
but he's a computer scientist from italy
and he did some work with functional
programming
and he actually found a way he proposed
a way of structuring semantics
to describe state exceptions and etc
side effects
in programming
and he did this using a abstract branch
of mathematics
and category theory called monads
so what are these monads in category
theory
well they're also known as clic triples
or
or triple and it's endofunctor together
with two natural transformations and
it's used in theory a pair of the joint
functions
so alice thought about this and um it
didn't quite sink
in as she would have hoped so she took
another bite of cheese
another sip of wine and she sat by the
fire and
her toes were feeling quite warm and she
just decided just to close her eyes just
for a moment and
maybe this would somehow sink in so she
closed her eyes
and she was suddenly awakened by her
phone going off
and had a strange picture of a rabbit on
there which was not there before
and it got even stranger because the
next thing she saw
was a message saying you were late
even stranger than this it said she was
late for
a monad symposium in 15 minutes so she
looked around she still seemed to be in
her chair by the fire with her plate of
cheese
but she heard something russell kind of
running past
and going down the cat door in her
basement so she had to get up and
investigate so she went to the door
to her basement and opened it up and
started going down the stairs
and the stairs actually seemed much
bigger than they normally did
and all of a sudden she started seeing
strange things on the wall
it almost looked like formulas
so so she kept going down a little bit
more
and another thing would pop up very very
odd
she kept going down the stairs a little
bit more
this was getting very strange and in
fact the stairs were going on a lot
longer than she had remembered the
staircase
and in fact it seemed like a cartoon
because she finally looked down at the
stairs and realized there weren't any
more stairs there at all and she just
started falling
so she fell until she landed quite
softly nicely
into a room that just had a really big
door
there was no way that she could reach
the handle of the store there was
nothing in it no tables no chairs
nothing she had no clue what to do next
in fact the only thing that could give
her a shred of hope
was a little piece of paper that said
say hello on it
so she tried it she looked at the door
and said
hello and the door answers her back
but with a question is it true that this
could be a monadic return operation
okay let me see defining a function
return
takes a parameter of a value and it
returns that value back in a function
let's see this in action so if i would
just call this on a string
say jelly it would give me back a
function
and enclosure of course we can execute
functions by putting this in another set
of parens
so if we execute return jelly it'll give
us
jelly so she really didn't know whether
this was or not but she had a 50 50
chance so
she said sure the door said yes
because the return object is a function
which is a container
or a monadic value that when executed is
jelly
okay so the door asks you another
question
is it true that this could be a monadic
return operation
okay this is labeled return as before
and it takes a value but it doesn't do
anything to it it just returns back that
value
i'm suspicious so if we just give it a
string
no no because return object jelly is not
a function
and a container or a magnetic value
okay the door asks another question
is it true that this could be a monetic
bind operation
let me see so if we call bind
with a monadic value in a function
and we take this monetic value
and we execute it we get the value back
so we apply the function to it
maybe let's see this in action so if we
define a function called with toast
and it takes a string and then it
returns back that string concatenated
with toast and
and we execute it and we put it in the
bind so we say
bind and we have to do return jelly to
make a monadic value
and then we say with toast for our
function it gives us back a container or
a monadic value but if we do that paren
trick on it again
we'll get back toast and jelly so it
applied that function to it
so again alice wasn't too sure but this
felt kind of good so she said yes the
door looked pleased
said yes because it takes a momentic
value and it applies a function
and it returns a monadic value
well this was all very interesting to
alice but she still didn't see how it
was going to get her
farther in opening the door so she
started looking very perplexed and upset
about this
and the door noticed and started asking
her more pointed question
can you write a monadic return function
for yourself
alice thought
well if i define me to be a string
i could write return me and it would be
a momentic value
and then i could execute and it would be
me
the door said good well he didn't say
good but you could tell
he said can you write a function that
makes you grow and returns a magnetic
value
okay so we have a return function for
myself
we could define a function that takes a
string
and it kind of cheats but it's going to
take the last character from that string
concatenate it to it so when we call
grow me it's going to be a momentic
value of course
and when we execute it it's going to be
me with an extra e on the end
so we're growing the string and we're
growing ourselves
so the door said good so now can you use
this monadic bind operation to grow
so let's define another function called
mgrow
so it's going to take a mometic value
and it's going to use this bind
on the monadic value and grow so
here we could start we have to start off
with the monadic value return me
so we call m grow on that it returns a
monadic value and if we execute it
again with extra trends it turns off me
with the extra e
alice looked pretty pleased at this and
the door said good
we'll now grow bigger let's chain these
so you could she chained it three times
and she ended up growing quite a bit
and there's another way we can write
this it's a little bit more
aesthetically pleasing and closure
using a macro the threading macro so we
can say return me
and do 3m grows and the same thing we'd
get back me
so the door was looking very pleased
indeed
and alice grew
and she was able to open the door
so the next scene she came into was and
this wonderful floor
forest glen there was nice path
and she figured well she might as well
try to find this monadic
with this monad symposium so she
wandered down the path for a bit
beautiful trees everywhere and the path
went straight for a while and then it
forked
there's a path either right or left
and she didn't really know which way to
go there was a tree right in the middle
of the path
and she stood there for a minute
contemplating which direction might be
the best way to go
and as she stood there she heard a
rustling in the tree
and she looked up
and there was a smiling cat there in the
tree
so she did whatever you would do if
there was a smiling cat in the tree
she decided to ask it for directions so
um mr smiling cat do you would you
please tell me
which way it is to the monad symposium
the smiling cat said ah you want
directions
to have directions you have to have
where you are
and the destination and then you can
have directions
you obviously know where you want to go
but the problem is you don't really know
where you are
do you so if you have a function like
this
which take a parameter where you are
starting
directions let's see
it's kind of a silly function but it'll
do for just explaining it
if we had start as a string we could
concatenate that with a
random right or left and return that
wrapped in
a monadic value
so we could then define m directions
that takes a monadic value and binds
that
to this function directions
so if you started with here the string
here
and you wrapped it in the your turn
function of course
and then you called a couple directions
on it you would start with here you'd
end up with here
and right or left you know since it's
random it could have been right or right
but just for
the sake of argument we're doing right
and left
so the problem with this is that if you
don't know where you are
and you start off with a nil it just
blows up with a null pointer exception
so the cat said can you think of any way
you can get around this and fix it
so alice sat there and thought for a
moment
she said let me see
if we took this bind function and if we
modified it slightly
we could take this monadic value when it
comes in
and get the value out of it and then we
could check to see if it was nil
so if it was nil we can just return
that monadic the monadic value
of nil but if it wasn't now we can apply
the function to it
so that might work
so she tried it and it didn't work it
turned nil
instead of blowing up the cat smiled
even bigger this time
and said that way so she thanked the cat
very nicely for showing her the
directions
and as she watched the cat slowly
disappeared
only a pair of parens
so she headed down the way the cat had
indicated
down the path
and there's a bit a little bit that she
had to walk
and suddenly it it she entered a
clearing a forest clearing
and there was this beautiful tea set up
all silver play settings for eight
but the only problem was is there was
only one person there
and that person was dressed in an
astronaut suit
and if this wasn't strange enough there
was nothing else on the table
but a burrito
so alice was very confused and she
didn't know what to say
next when the astronaut came up to her
saying
you're finally here you are so late we
are going to have to cancel the whole
monad symposium
please get started immediately well
alice didn't know what to make of this
she said i'm sorry there must have been
some sort of mistake
i was just here to see a monad symposium
definitely i i had nothing to do or
present
he said oh dear it's it's quite natural
to have
nervous jitters i'll help you get
started let's sit down and you can say
this together with me
monads are like astronauts
alice said um i i'm not seeing it
i'm sorry
so the astronaut said
okay maybe we should start with
something simpler
let's try saying this with me monads are
like burritos
alice said i i i'm sorry
you're confusing me i don't really know
what you're talking about then she said
oh i i think you're referring to some
blog posts that were comparing
monads to astronauts and burritos oh
yeah i tried to read those but
i'm afraid they only got me more
confused i i don't think this is the
right way to go about it at all
i'm afraid at this the astronaut sat
down at the table
he took off his helmet and his face was
bright red
he was very exasperated he said fine
if you don't want to talk about
astronauts
suits or burritos i want you to sit down
and have some tea maybe you could do
something useful like
tell us how many cubes of sugar there
are as we go around and drink our tea
she thought about this and said well at
least it's a problem we can work with
this
so we can make a function
for um having t let's call it mt
and it would take some parameters it
would take a monatic value
and it's also going to take a little
extra it's going to take the name
of the person having t so we're going to
have two parameters this time
so we're going to use our bind function
of course on lumetic value
but this time we're just going to
actually define the function in here
and we're going to return the string
of the value concatenated with the name
of the person having t
so let's see this in action
so if we start off as me having t
and then we call m t u then it's going
to return the string
me and u
so we might have to also change this
return function slightly so we can
accommodate this state
of the sugar cubes that we're starting
out with
so instead of
having just a value that we're returning
wrapped
we're going to return a function of the
state
with a vector of the value and the state
so a little bit of a change but if we're
modifying the return
then we also have to modify modify the
bind
so this monadic value we're going to now
destructure
into a here we go it's a value
and the state new so remember we have to
get the value we have to give it a state
and then we're going to get the answer
back here
and then once we get the answer back we
can apply the function to this value
and then we have a new state and we can
wrap this all in a function of the state
so this is now what we're going to be
returning so let's see some examples of
this
so the nice thing is is we don't have to
change this mt
function at all but if we start off with
me
and we call mtu
then we also start off with 10 sugar
cubes
we're going to end up with me and u and
10.
so we know we have 10 sugar cubes okay
this is good
we have we have state in here now we can
do something with it we can
actually track the sugar cubes
so if we define a take sugar function
that takes the monetic value what we
could do is bind that monetic value
to something that modifies a state so
it's going to take the value
but here's the important part it's going
to decrement
decrement the state before passing it
back
so let's see some examples in this
so this actually should be kind of on
one line here but we could say return me
so i have t and then i take a sugar cube
and then you have t
we start off with 10 sugar cubes and we
execute this we're going to end up with
me
and u and 9 sugar cubes very cool
so let's try this again we start off
with me
take two sugar cubes and then you have t
we start off with 10 then we're going to
end up with b
and u 8. so she felt very pleased
they could have t and she could figure
out how many tea
how many sugar cubes were used during
the tea
so she looked over at the astronaut who
now had his helmet up
and he seemed to be much happier
and he even offered her a cup of tea
which she kindly accepted
and she actually felt kind of pleased
with herself and as she was drinking the
tea
the room started spinning
and as it started spinning she realized
that she had actually been implementing
monads
during this whole time at the door
she had implemented the identity monad
so and the important stuff here is in
the return in the bind
you can see that all it was really doing
was applying a function to the value
so she had this function that made her
grow
and all it did was apply that function
over and over again it made the
ease grow on there
and then at the tree with the cat she
had actually implemented the maybe moon
ad
and again you can kind of look in the
return in the bind to see what's
happening here
that she checked the value to see that
if it was nil or not
if it was nil she returned the nil
wrapped and if it if it wasn't nil she
went ahead and applied the function
so she did some air handling here
and at the tea party she had implemented
the state moon ad
so it's a little more complex here but
you can still see what's going on when
you look at the return in the bind
that there is a new state and this is a
function of the state
and the bind is keeping track of it as
well
so in his return take sugar function she
decremented the state
so that she keep track of it and modify
it
so very cool and
all these examples had some things in
common
the three monad laws
so two of these laws have to do with
this return
acting as a neutral element of bind so
it it's kind of complicated when you
look at that in the rule so if we see
some examples here
so if you call if you do return me and
then we bind it to grow
it applies that function so it makes the
me grow
and if you same thing if you just call
the grow on me
it does the same thing so that takes
care of the left unit which is the first
monad law
so the second law has to do with the
other side which is the right unit
and you've got well it's easier to see
an example
that if you if you call the bind on the
return me and then you use this return
function
it's just just gonna return the thing
that you started out with
and the same thing is if you call return
me and execute it of course
then you end up with the me
so that's the two moned laws that kind
of deal with the same thing
now the third moland law is a little bit
more complicated it's associative law
and it just talks about the ordering
really of things
that if you bind binding two functions
in succession is the same as binding one
function that can be determined from
them
so
here if you call a couple binds and a
couple grows
it's going to expand the me and that's
the same thing that if
you would call the bind on the return me
and then put it in a function that's
doing the same thing
so just an ordering
so alice was reflecting on all this
as she was kind of spinning around and
you know thinking about the monad laws
and thinking about all the monads she's
implemented
and she heard uh kind of a beeping a
little bit far away
and the beeping got a little bit louder
and a little bit louder
it was her phone again for a minute she
thought it looked like a rabbit but then
i went back to her normal phone
and she looked around and she was back
in her chair
by the fire and by her cheese and by the
books
and she thought wow that was the
weirdest dream
i have ever had i should watch the
cheese
[Music]
so in summary we we've we saw three
types of moon ads that we implemented
there are many more types of moon ads
they're io moon ads collections monads
continuation writer monads etc etc and
they all obey the moon ad laws
so just so you know we've just scratched
the surface here
monads are all about having your cake
and eating it too
so you can have these pure functions and
pure functional
languages and you can keep all the messy
and impure stuff
on the outside so it's a way of
structuring
your programs
so some practical uses of monads they're
very useful
when you have things in kind of a
pipeline in sequential execution
examples of this would be parsing
fuzzing
web request processing they're also very
use
useful for re reusable modular side
effect processing
like if you have things where you want
to do error handling again and again
logging and you can kind of use them as
modules as you go along in your pipeline
and they also allow you to keep your
business logic
clean and pure and your functions and do
all your side effects
kind of things that you want to do
outside that
and the most important thing is to use
caution
when mixing monads and cheese
so resources when i was
learning about monads philip wadler's
papers are great
they're a little bit heavy reading i
highly recommend them
um adam smycheck he's got a video
and i've fondness for him because it was
the first video
i watched i was like oh yeah i think i
get this
and a lot of my examples follow from
some of the examples that he
he gave although he didn't really have a
lot of the cheese on it
so and jim dewey he's got a great series
of blog posts
on moned's enclosure he's done a series
for closure west that
actually some of the monad laws i took
from his examples
very good and there's a closure library
closure algomonads by conrad henson
that is a very useful library and he
actually goes through a lot of good
examples in his
documentation blog post about monads as
well you can check out
so that's all that i have